Elon Musk owns Twitter and now Twitter
is owning Elon Musk his first few weeks
of ownership have been interesting and
wouldn't you know it when you like 44
billion dollars on fire for the lulls
you're bound to run into some legal
headaches now things are changing so
fast that by the time you watch this
video the platform could be gone it
could be Borrowed by Mark Zuckerberg it
could be turned into an nft I guess or
doing business as usual who knows but
here's a quick rundown of everything
that musk has accomplished so far he
fired half of Twitter's total Workforce
and then scrambled to hire some of them
back after stating that Twitter should
be politically neutral he endorsed the
Republican party before the midterms a
bet that quickly backfired he announced
a new rule requiring users engage in
parity to include parody in their bio
and then when that didn't work to
include it in their Twitter name which
is exactly the same thing that the onion
just demolished as being contradictory
to the entire point of parody he
promised advertisers that Twitter would
not become a free-for-all hellscape and
then loosened up on content moderation
resulting in a measurable increase in
people being awful racist or homophobic
and leading to a whole bunch of
advertisers leaving the platform or at
least temporarily he got rid of the blue
check verification system and replaced
it with an eight dollar a month
subscription service that didn't verify
user identity allowing people to
impersonate Brands and celebrities
that's how we got a seemingly verified
George W bush tweeting I miss killing
Iraqis and a seemingly verified Rudy
Giuliani saying Nancy Pelosi and I do
not agree on many things but them things
hang in I'll tell you what
now all this has been great fun to
observe but now that Twitter is a raging
dumpster fire musk has to contend with
some serious legal issues including how
he was forced to buy Twitter in the
first place the FTC Gauntlet that is
facing Twitter and then there's the
wrongful termination suits and possible
bankruptcy it's a real sues Sue now when
we last visited Elon Musk in Twitter
musk was arguing that Twitter had misled
him about the number of bots on Twitter
and that it's now former leadership had
fired employees without his consent so
he was calling off the deal at the time
I speculated that it would be tough for
him to get out of that deal to buy the
company take it from Devin from the past
Delaware courts have been known to order
specific performance in just such a
situation as this Twitter sued musk for
a specific performance in the Delaware
Chancery Court I.E they wanted to force
him to purchase Twitter at the agreed
upon price the Chancery Court has
jurisdiction to hear all matters related
to equity which means that it had the
power to compel him to go through with a
purchase musk wanted a discovery process
that would take months if not years to
complete but in July the Court ruled
that musk and Twitter needed to be ready
for trial by October that's an insanely
fast timeline for a major trial but such
is life in the Delaware Chancery Court
they do not mess around presumably
feeling that he did not have enough time
to make a decent case or just saw the
writing on the wall musk went through
with the purchase and bought the company
at the original sales price of 44
billion on October 28th so in the end it
was much a sue about nothing now musk
fans what are they muscovites I guess
rejoiced because he promised them that
he would be a champion of free speech
musk had assured us that Twitter is the
new New Town Square and everyone has a
First Amendment right to more or less
say whatever they want on the platform
though he did begin to backtrack almost
immediately as musk said by free speech
I simply mean that which matches the law
I'm against censorship that goes far
beyond the law though musk's actions
didn't match his words almost
immediately when Twitter users started
making fun of him he suspended their
accounts Kathy Griffin probably has an
entire mug of billionaire Tears by now
and short musk has a legal right to be a
delicate sensitive boy it just doesn't
match his particular rhetoric the first
member prohibits the United States
government from censoring speech but
private companies or private individuals
can censor speech if they want to if
musk wants to shut down speech from
progressives and liberals and promote
speech from conservative voices he has a
right to do that or vice versa he can
ban people who hurt his feelings and he
can turn Twitter into a hellscape of
bullying and racism if he wants to do
that that much is obvious however that
choice is not without consequences and
musk got a lesson in the free market
almost immediately at least 50 percent
of Twitter's advertisers have fled the
platform since musk took over and just
as musk has a right to run Twitter the
way that he wants more or less
advertisers are free to not advertise on
the platform that's the free market and
work there now the issue here is that
musk claims to be a free speech
absolutist he apparently believes not
just in free speech in the sense of the
government can't censor people but also
consequence free speech and that's just
not how things work and we know this in
particular because Elon Musk keeps
firing Twitter employees who either make
fun of Elon or say things that Elon
doesn't agree with now he can do that
subject to some limitations we'll talk
about later but we can also make fun of
him for his Free Speech hypocrisy now at
the same time musk temporarily ditched a
verification in favor of a pay-per-blue
policy and one of the consequences from
that was that an Eli Lilly impersonator
promised to make insulin free and some
have speculated this might have cost the
company around 15 billion dollars in
market share though I'm skeptical of the
causation there but still this deters
companies from even wanting to engage on
Twitter let alone pay the company to run
advertisements now musk says he's going
to create a Content moderation Council
to review suspended accounts but he also
has fired the entire Twitter Safety and
Security team so he'll have to build
that Council from scratch now musk also
fired 80 of Twitter's contractors around
the world which maintained the core
infrastructure services that keep the
site up and running that's probably not
important and as much as musk would like
to believe that the advertiser problem
is caused by activist woke Brands it
might have just as much to do with
instability and potentially a
deteriorating site experience which
might only get worse and a day after the
mass termination must confirm the
dumpster fire tweeting by the way I'd
like to apologize for Twitter being
super slow in many countries app is
doing more than 1 000 poorly bashed rpcs
just to render a home timeline and
independent reports also state that
Twitter's code base suffers from
sinusoidal depleneration which could be
fixed with the proper flux capacitors
and proton packs now it's been fun
watching Elon just tweet through all of
this but in all the assignment he seems
to have overlooked a big legal issue
which is Twitter's consent decree with
the Federal Trade Commission Twitter's
Chief privacy officer Chief compliance
officer and Chief Information Security
Officer abruptly quit shortly after Elon
rolled out new product features without
the security reviews that the FTC
required in its decree with the company
the employees went on slack and warned
their colleagues that musk's new plans
are extremely dangerous for our users
also given the FTC can and will find
Twitter billions of dollars pursuant to
the FTC consent order extremely
detrimental to Twitter's longevity as a
platform and the employees then posted a
link to whistleblower Aid a non-profit
Law Firm that helps employees report
corporate or government wrongdoing now
what caused musk's privacy and security
officers to issue such a dire warning
well it started with a consent decree
and the government agency responsible
for Consumer Protection the Federal
Trade Commission it all goes back to
2009 when Twitter's lack security
processes allowed hackers to obtain
unauthorized administrative control of
Twitter including both access to
non-public user information nation and
private tweets hackers were also able to
send out phony tweets from any account
in 2010 the FTC sued Twitter for
misleading consumers about the privacy
of their personal information and for
failing to protect user phone numbers in
2011 Twitter entered into a consent
decree with the FTC a consent decree is
in agreement that settles a dispute
without the defendant admitting guilt or
liability the consent decree has to be
approved by a judge making it
enforceable by the court so the Twitter
consent decree barred the company from
making misleading statements about the
extent to which it protects the security
privacy and confidentiality of
non-public consumer information and
under the terms of the decree Twitter
agreed to maintain a comprehensive
information security program and allow
an independent auditor to assess its
programs every other year for the first
10 years after the decree in May of 2022
just as musk was purchasing Twitter the
FTC accused the company violating the
original consent decree according to the
FTC complaint quote more than 140
million Twitter users provided email
addresses or telephone numbers to
Twitter based on Twitter deceptive
statements that their information would
be used for specific purposes related to
account security in reality Twitter is
accused of using the personal data to
Target users with advertising Twitter
settled this claim paid 140 million
dollars in fines and entered into a new
consent decree the terms of the updated
consent decree require significantly
more stringent monitoring of Twitter's
privacy and security claims which are
audited by a third party Twitter agreed
to conduct a privacy assessment of any
new products it launches and provide the
assessment to the FTC Rihanna fefrikorn
who used to be Twitter's outside counsel
summarized Twitter's obligations like
this but if Twitter so much as sneezes
it has to do with privacy review
beforehand now we don't know if and to
what extent Twitter is violating the FTC
consent decree but we do know that Elon
Musk has a history of not particularly
caring what government agencies tell him
to do so it's not clear if Twitter's New
or Old staff are in compliance with the
consent decree but more on that we'll
probably come out eventually and well
all this is going on Elon Musk took the
stand on Wednesday in the tornado
shareholder derivative suit that seeks
to nullify the 2018 pay package that he
received as Tesla's CEO under the terms
of that deal musk's compensation would
be divided into 12 batches of stock that
would be dispersed as must-hit
predetermined Milestones which he did as
a result musk received over 50 billion
dollars in Tesla's stock now these are
difficult cases to win generally courts
don't like to review the business
decisions of a company this class action
argues the Tesla's board of directors
were unduly influenced by musk and
failed to disclose crucial information
about the deal to the shareholders who
approved the deal but musk had to
testify in that case and because he's a
legal genius he implied that he doesn't
need to comply with consent decrees in
reference to an SEC consent decree musk
apparently said the consent decree was
made under duress an agreement made
under duress is not valid as a
foundation of law to which he was asked
are you trained as a lawyer to which he
replied I have some familiarity with the
legal system if you're in enough
lawsuits you pick up a few things along
the way the thing is the FTC doesn't
mess around many have argued that the
SEC doesn't have enough teeth but the
FTC sometimes in conjunction with the
doj can make things hurt not only with
much bigger fines but sometimes jail
just ask Uber's former Chief security
officer who was recently convicted on
federal charges for obstruction against
the FTC or ask Facebook who got hit with
a 5 billion dollar fine for violating a
consent decree related to Cambridge
analytica and following on the heels of
these Mass firings Elon apparently sent
another late night email in which he
told Twitter that they needed to be more
hardcore that they needed to respond
they were willing to put in grueling
hours or not and they had until 5 PM to
respond or they would be fired with
three months of severance now given the
added debt that musk added to Twitter
musk claims that he needs to make things
profitable at Twitter which is why he
laid off half of Twitter's staff and
meanwhile allegedly a lawyer on
Twitter's privacy team has apparently
overheard musk's lawyer say that Elon is
willing to take on a huge amount of risk
in retaliation to this company and users
because Elon puts Rockets into space and
he's not afraid of the FTC and also the
whistleblowing lawyer also said the
Twitter Engineers would have to take on
the burden of personally certifying that
the products they designed for Twitter
comply with the consent decree now this
is obviously hearsay but it may also be
true because there haven't exactly been
some vociferous denials of it either now
if true then Twitter is requiring the
engineers to take on all the risk but
the consent decree does not allow
individual employees to certify
Twitter's privacy and security systems
the FTC agreement requires Twitter to
submit any significant change in
operations to an outside auditor before
it can be implemented and according to
the Washington Post the FTC expects
Twitter to submit a new audit in January
the sources said that before musk even
took over the company was already
scrambling to hire enough people to meet
that deadline and the FTC issued a
statement quote when you're tracking
recent developments in Twitter with deep
concern no CEO or company is above the
law and companies must follow our
consent decrees our revised consent
order gives us new tools to ensure
compliance and we are prepared to use
them and that takes us to live paper in
employment law because there have been
lots of changes for Twitter employees
musk has fired almost 4 000 Twitter
workers and although musk has the right
to fire employees this right is not
unlimited Twitter still has to follow
federal state and local laws with the
federal workers adjustment and
retraining notification act also known
as the warn act that generally requires
businesses with 100 or more employees to
provide 60 days notice before engaging
in Mass layoffs Warren defines layoffs
as those affecting at least 500
employees during a 30-day period though
employers can provide workers with 60
days of severance pay in lieu of giving
notice and terminated California
employees have already filed suit under
the Warren act in comparable state laws
though musk has several defenses to
their claims he claims that he offered
to pay some employees through January
4th 2023 which could constitute
compliance with a 60-day rule some
employees were offered severance package
but we don't know enough of the details
yet to determine whether the packages
complied with the law and musk can also
say that the employees were fired for
cause which was his defense in a similar
lawsuit against Tesla when X Tesla
employees sued musk under the Warren act
he argued that they were all fired for
poor performance and were not layoffs
requiring advanced notice and musk is
also taking a Hardline approach to
remote workers he sent a 2 34 am email
informing the entire Workforce that they
needed to work in the office for at
least 40 hours a week unless they're
given approval to work elsewhere and
musk said that he would personally
approve all work from home requests
quote obviously if you are physically
unable to travel to an office or have a
critical personal obligation then your
absence is understandable now musk has
the right to require employees to work
in the office if it doesn't violate
other laws he'll have to exercise this
discretion without running afoul of the
Americans with Disabilities Act and
other laws prohibiting discrimination
against people with disabilities he'll
also have to follow the FMLA and other
laws that protect an employee's right to
take time off if they're sick or caring
for an ill family member now generally
companies of these size have HR
departments to handle these kinds of
requests and obligations but sure Elon
is going to personally make all of these
determinations I'm sure that's going to
work out fine so where does this just
leave Twitter well maybe bankruptcy even
Elon has explicitly stated that
bankruptcy is on the table which is not
something that you want to hear from a
new owner just weeks into their tenure
by most accounts Elon paid too much for
Twitter and saddled it with too much
debt it's possible that Twitter shuts
down but it's more likely that it would
just go into bankruptcy and the debtors
would take a massive haircut or you can
threaten bankruptcy to force debtors to
take a haircut without formally going
into bankruptcy and there are reports
that the banks are currently marketing
their debt to others and have received
offers of 60 cents on the dollar though
it seems that they want at least 70
cents on the dollar others have
speculated that Twitter might only be
worth 8 billion dollars at this point
meaning that Elon and his fellow
financiers would lose 80 percent of
their Investments but I guess it could
have been worse they could have
purchased FTX but now that Twitter has
fired all the people responsible for
making the site safe you can never be
too careful online and that's where
today's sponsored nordvpn can help
because you know that incognito mode
isn't actually Incognito right and
nordvpn is more than just to VPN it
comes with a whole Suite of threat
protection tools for example if you
follow some of your favorite creators on
social media you might have heard the
stories of channels getting hacked
basically a Creator loses access after a
successful attack or a leaked password
and in fact Alex's Corner one of our
nebula friends recently got their
YouTube channel stolen and turned into a
repository for cryptocurrency scam
videos but nordvpn's threat protection
includes specific features to warn you
about phishing links as well as features
like a blocker for malicious ads and
dark web monitoring to see if your
passwords have been leaked and of course
nordvpn is a great VPN with Nord you can
surf the web anonymously and your
location stays private it allows me to
set my location all over the world which
lets me access different versions of my
favorite websites and when I'm out of
the country and try to connect to Gmail
or a bunch of other things that I'm
logged into all those accounts usually
would freak out and tell me that I'm
being hacked so now I just reroute my
connection to the US and my Gmail and
everything is perfectly happy so if
you'd like to give nordvpn a try click
on the link that's on screen right now
or in the description to get a two-year
plan with a huge discount plus four
additional months free and is completely
risk-free with nord's 30-day money-back
guarantee so click on the link below to
get a two-year plan with four additional
months for free with a risk-free 30-day
money-back guarantee as well and after
that click on this box over here for
more legal eagle or I'll see you in
court